rise in the California economy.
My name's Tasha burner were
rather like to welcome you. The
end. To be back as many of you
know I was elected the state
SMS council my for over. Seven
up in the world. So I did get
your Cooper mission today- I
want to thank the city of
Anthony is for allowing us to
you chamber we have city
manager Karen breast there on
the back thank you so much for
calling us to be the chamber.
And we a hard stop at five PM
so we'll- go to public. Kind of
look. I like to encourage the
rule. That we have an instant
it is that if you agree with
that statement. Do little
chance. That way we see you all
the way in the back that you
agree. We can. Bonta. And I
want to thank. The coming
senators that we have here we
have. O'donnell assembly member
Todd Gloria. And is that lay
ahead- and addressing the
impacts of sea level rise
specifically as they relate to
the California economy so we
know there are lots of impacts
of sea level rise to many
different aspects so when I.
Look at this and I think about
sea level rise my California
economy especially what it
means. In San Diego county but
throughout the state. The thing
one is the M. it's gonna and
then the second as our
infrastructure and the third
which. I think is probably the
most timely when we look at now
that we have in del Mar. To do
with the at. And of course
those just. This focus areas
the all have- but I'd like to-
really reiterate we know the
sea level is rising. We have.
High tides and for. Ocean our
direct tax in California this
is. Putting now and we just saw
the reports that more and of
the rail corridor in del Mar
has fallen away we know this is
we're probably a little too
late for this discussion so
when we talk about our issues
and we think about them. Really
like us to look at how do we
move forward to action. It a
lot amber this. We have. Cut
pressing issues now throughout
our state that we need to
address we know. Will
governments have. I was in a
city council I was a co chair
of the sea level rise
subcommittee. Where we were
looking at our phone local
infrastructure in this area and
I know with stand out of the
showing preservation working
group we looked and take a take
an evaluation. Of the entire
coastline and sandy of county
on where is double structure
and. Areas that we can come
together and work together best
to make sure we have the best
outcome not only for today but
for tomorrow. And then we know
as a state where our priorities
can be and how do we better
coordinate these efforts into
real change. So before first
path to get to open up to the
assembly members and senator
Bates for any. Comments that
you license will have thank you
so much for being here. Madam
but this and I just. Asian your
district today of these are all
all three are fine
representatives of your area I
know Mr Gloria you're next door
but still- you you to work
together very well along with
the senators so I appreciate
the opportunity to sit here
today and really learn more
than I already know because I
don't. Know enough but why am I
here- specifically my district
have went back to see low rise
I represent seventy sunny
district. Long home stand
Catalina island so ground zero
right I'm a priest Adam economy
on to this hearing it's not
just about sea level rise but
the impact struck on me I
represent that both ports right
let one of largest port
complexes in the world. And sea
level rise has already
impacting them I represent a
lot of homes on the beach.
Already ma'am I was reading
some articles as I came down. I
to this hearing and I think the
two numbers resonated in. Mind
the most were ninety nine over
the last hundred years we've
lost nine inches of beach but
in the next four years will
lose nine feet of beach and
that's going to have a
significant impact on our last
stop on economy we need to be
prepared. For that fact and as
the local. In the last few
years we've seen climate change
impact our fire season well I
think we're going to face the
same dynamic. On the ocean
front and we need to be
prepared for that night you
know our coaching building
homes these places. Are
starting. Their bill. Homes in
the persons and then ultimately
our economy insurance rates
etcetera so with that I thank
you again madam chair. For the
invitation here today and I
look forward to listening and
learning more. Of thank you
madam chair nothing construed.
Offers comments I'm glad that
does that so making a it's good
to see. The great Khali among.
Yeah to be set up thank you we
owe. The cook and of. Our to
represent isn't quite not a C.
O. del Mar and so on a beach I
see America surged in his head
thank you for putting him on
the agenda Medina has been able
and pourtant voice on this
issue in his community really
taken so the tougher issues on
how you implement or deal with
this and so I'm grateful that
you're giving him. The platform
to share I think other cities
could learn what. May for
making time today. I'm just. I
want to let everyone know that.
Boerner Horvath and I have been
collaborating China state do.
See an budget next year. One
you have a post là. Ask your
state senator president pro tem
Toni Atkins able secure
significant funding tried state
for will stay busy in the more
plus area though quizzes are
emergency. The. In this right
there ago anyway certainly add
my appreciation to. AB. Putting
this together I think we're all
here the bill here find
solutions. Heard from her seat
we've also heard often
environmental style. Concerns
than everyone else on points of
this problem we aye the Anthony.
Bob purchased a home here in
Encinitas we still have it and
we used to visit the beach here
always it was always slow so
much fun so recently after the
bluff collapse I toured the
beaches and I was shocked
shocked to see how much how
much is not left. In terms of-
what has happened over those
several decades so see rice's
real of for those who are not
comfortable with that I am very
comfortable with that because
I've witnessed it it affects my
district at thirty six Senate
district runs from Rancho Santa
Margarita yeah and the Orange
County down through and so need
of sorry here in north San
Diego county so I have- coastal
cities all along the way
recently and send committee-
coastal trail that. We work so
long I was on the Orange County
Board of supervisors to ensure
that we have the funding for
that and it would go through
all the various sub permitting-
we lost a part of that due to a
bluff collapse so now that
coastal trail and someone. Who
I thought was absolutely
wonderful- passed away and it
was projects so I would hope
some day we it's going to be
named in her honor back
thinking about I felt a few
tears from heaven when that
happened we also have to
Capistrano. Beach we lost out
to with the high price and that
was a huge recreational area
for the people in south Orange
County cities of data points
and committee and surrounds so
it's real in it so- I think
great that we're all here in a
bipartisan way with experts
that will help us I navigate
this very very difficult.
Problem and the solution that
we can all get behind it is
going to be a little bit of
every part of the question is
going to there's to be a little
bit a compromise that have
staff to happen but every
France that's what I'm here to
hold to hear from experts and
how we approach. Thank you
again and yes time to pull. Sec
so I'd like to our first now is
sealevel rise what is the state
up against an invite doctor
mark Meer filled director
center for climate change
impacts and adaptations
institute of oceanography at
UCSD we're so fortunate to have
such a premier organization- an
institution of research just in
our backyard- really helping us
to address some of these.
Issues so the floor is yours.
Thank you for the invitation to
speak and I have a lot to cover
ten minutes all just jump right
to it. So what are we up
against what we facing so this
plot. Is a projection of sea
level into the future for this
is global but it is AB pregnant
for California as well. So
yellow line is where we've been
you can see will slow seal
riser last century. And then
those lines going off to the
right or projections are based
on different scenarios for. A
carbon use coverage a missions-
output and also some sciences
come to bear however how stable
the green. Of Greenland and
Antarctic ice sheets actually
are. All I want to emphasize
with this plot there's a lot of
detail here but what I want to
emphasize is first of all the-
magnitude of what the- okay the
man the man but that so we're
looking at anywhere from two to
eight feet of sea level rise by
the in the century. Depending
on the scenario. The other
thing size the uncertainty
there's a quite a range here
that it's hard to make
projections it's hard to make
actionable- decisions based on
this sort of information you
need more detail- the other bit
of it is the timing so where we
are right now at the end of the
yellow curve. You can hear the
our future for soft the- office.
Senate yes. It means that we
have a choice true path with-
for most think of. How to do it
will rise. Is how to the
mission. And how to keep. Going
forward our job. Is to take is
going to be. I was a with which
we keep that curve down. What
the set up. What's it all for
you coast fact. Some maps. A
moderate celos attempt to see
by some sort of center. On top
and storm thing significant but
he dot green it is flat after
of brown's owns a lot. Earlier
than flood. Zones and so where
you the server. Sure we can.
Some hot just Kobe San Diego of
inter county- Orange County new
Newport Newport beach. And that
flooding will bring with packs
us. Structure will be. Ports
and calm will have to deal with
the tires levels rational
Tiffany's talked about the
truck. And of course many of
the- other I'm supposed
highways are will be impacted.
And many facilities are among
the most which. Here's a that
hi fi. Not only the beaches
because there are to be a core
class this is work Adam young-
a survey that was done that was
just before one of these cliff
collapses. I just by
happenstance they happen to be
there and captured this- this
happens frequently I think Adam
show this last winter as being
a particularly. I'm. Or slides
were particularly prominent
throughout the winter season.
And we- heavy rains have
already started so that was the
fall let's see I think there's
a little dramatic pause here.
Keeps going. This is a natural
of phenomena. It's. As a more
weight impact at the shore là.
Honest two minutes later. And
shot and of course here the
card on top of that so- chest
heading home how vulnerable
that hold out. Yes okay so what
can we do that's why we're here
so what sort of actions can we
take our first of all a some of
the information that we have to
deal with while it's very
useful for long. Term
projections it's not it's hard
to make. A definitive plan.
Need more. In about. It a base
for that act quantifies the
impacts flooding on the Cup
what's the second can pass
along a rose to view what's-
ships and pose for since
shoreline that based on exit
it's hard to kind of scared
from to predict what happened.
Though not. Database out
percent I these infants are
happy day not likely to change
in the future. Also the
economic impact CNN but our
making some great strides in
imperial beach with a search
the dance team this was on a
forecast it was Mayes last last
winter and part of.
Understanding flooding is
understand. Pleasant so were
dedicate helping them get a
better understanding floods.
Answer and so they can do so
planet buzz how the world into
still Lara. Is in a couple of a
cat. Came that prop. Hey so. As
I said there's a lot of
uncertainty going forward click
those curves are- quite
different difference so you
have to do is buy step
proactive approach to-
adaptation so it's called
triggered an adept pathways. So
this is all some strategies to
try take some pretty open the
shore in their- search for. You
my are out of the- and I. The
left side. Water level rises
far enough for the be. Advice
all you have to some of us
structure or some sort harder
topic along shoreline that's
passed by a. I and eight and
that'll serve. Dozens and at
some point they have to be some
actual- up open what. I'm on
the impacts understand and the
when you make these ages what
is trigger. Prompt you from
current that's where the path
and someone. Think that have to
be back on scientific
information in these are all
decisions but again with that
and Ste information about flood
out has database of the flood
and cal yeah we'll be more
informed decisions about how
to. Approach this problem. The
other thing I should know it is
not. I think California should
look the way in a. In
developing our our innovative
strapped for sure. So what is
person strategy for our show as
many of the- guidance is a come
out are for sure lines on the
east coast. As we want to think
about California's house lines
are settlement our way climate
is the best management strategy
how often should happen what's
the grains. I'm sure we built.
Up if the blood was the living
shoreline it was put in a part
of. Task I really. Need to
understand the process and call
that. Affect California the
test for coastal protection.
Our research we don't I am the
team after that's for sure but
we do need to have such as a
better understanding of how
predict nama. So was slot.
Katie I see is if you. We have
the personal blocks over the
summer this is what. I get
scraps. Base of down that'll in
the new year I color plot
what's- but it be up Baker. Sir
with the light ours going. Of
the July. Thirty August
. Serves
in under. Leaving little fast
but what to do I the very start
embrace a mitigation policies
were tens and keep the rocks as
well going forward I'm we need
a slang misinformation so cal.
Present each year impacts
that's some will leave in some
form. Information that will.
Here's the we can catch on at
held is to find a data ways to
results. I are still to do it
in predict the mops of copal
change reaches plus. Calvet you
should the Senate demonstrate
prior to that also the
strategies go forward. See this
is the- run up hearing I'm
sorry next panel please have
three local elected from San
Diego cap- so like to call you
up the penalty- over here so
you can sit comfortably. On.
And we're protecting Costa
committees from the rising
seize the local government
perspective and experience we
have councilmember Kelly he
said even senators. Rank ocean
I am search did enough city of
them pearl beach thank you so
much we can start in that order
if you're comfortable
. I'm
hoping that my presentation
reached Dave chop this is a. So
I come here Catherine breaks
for is join us in the back
everybody welcome our favorite
mare. Accept research is also a
favorite mayor a lot favorite
mayors and San Diego county. Do
each of you have a presentation
so if not work on getting
killers presentation we can
start research is that work
out. Yeah present ride your
presentation okay well I can
get started as okay hasn't
Asians coming up so- marks
everything I was to say so. No
I'm just kidding but so my
name's Kelly she has he I'm-
here. So it's an honor to be
sitting here at a local
government. Perspective it's
all very humbling to remote
experts- and thank you only
members and are so are for the-
thing this in it. Rather than
Sacramento bee is. Thinking
into nida's opportune. It is
the this matters and see what
you know what. What is it that
we're trying to preserve and
how do that'll gather so. For
my presentation begins in the
men's room the way. Ono well
could I a let's see what we
need I can with a global. While
cal is right now presentation
when I recognize a council for.
A she's the hope hotel. Email.
The card Jerry Howard from
Anthony this what did I miss
any other elected officials
that I should have called out
I'm sorry. While working on the
present there's white will. You
know what what are you are you
to. Write one. Yellow they are
for mayor. And white one the
back thank you for joining us.
It's like the way the public in
the way on the city council.
That would like to give
presentations. Thank you. Ask
yeah I thought we had thought
we had pink slips Republican I
realized no longer on the city
council we don't have. Okay so
prior to- my time here on
council I served at the
Leucadia main street station.
And so were a chamber of
commerce Julie for a historic
visit district. It has been a
lot of time. North coast one of
which is the historic business.
That's also one of our
principal transportation. I'm
one good to talk about
intersection of steel right and
Oakley because of the two
topics that I'm passionate
about. So up. Is there a local
sobre universe all mom pop
businesses just this past may
I'm as you can see an event
poster we are so proud of our-
into the code we us so much of
a tentative our small business
up into the fact that were
beach adjacent we are visitor
search commercial not serves
both. Locals and- as far as far
as imperial valley imperial. Me
out zona and you see that
during the summer. So beach
people come here for. A for our
businesses. I'm some one is
that it was created to be a-
just. To conveyance that's all
it was designed to do getting
people from LA to town San
Diego or to. For the years
we've seen that the
functionality of this road has
changed as a community. Charlie.
Brown's was born I think it's
always been not the corner here
of ash hi everyone I want and
that was all- auto serving a
card it ship and recently they
respond to the changing culture
and they re open and read. It
as Charlie's electric by. Good
example in a ship in our
economy. That beautiful store
that was struck by local
artists are him out and you can
see. Lights were. Oct Bob. Food
so highly one one really is our
town square it's a these are
people come together it has to
about- in and of itself to
just. From point a to point B.
our our our like. Both our
economy and to coastal act yes
in taxes start talking about
all rights because not only is
it transportation but also
these other two. Parts of what
it what the Stevenson it assist
is made up. So what we're not
lose that in thirty three sixty
six per cent of beaches
southern California this is. So
hard right around I don't even
think that I fully done it yet
and most. Armored. Zero beaches
which is Annie this is our
majority of B. we really only
have two beaches left that you
can go during even a medium
tied which- one is now in
Cardiff and other one is
moonlight beach. And so here
to- images to illustrate the
child that we're up against.
The left you'll see a photo
from the twenty eighteen stone
steps toward on test is. A much
loved community event. Gives
birth to our small businesses.
Because people come for this
event people have a living area
for a long time they- they come
back to locate enjoy it. But as
you can see there was no beach
and so. They kind of left
everybody thinking I can still
surf but there's just this
specter. Vent that's missed. So
what you see over the years is
fewer and fewer days that we
can actually enjoy our beaches
and the other effects of that
is that. Our recreational
opportunities are limited our
exercise opportunities are
limited and this is a really
threaten ecosystem in southern
California. That we're seeing
get smaller and smaller by the
day. This year the San papers
are out there so take a look if
you have a chance to get down
there- and on the right that's
a an example of a success so
this is the living shoreline
project- I found out recently
that Larry Giles who's our
marines. Safety captain. He is
a fourth generation and
intonation. It's a need. And
that he he remembered when this
was- do not attack and so this
was sort of impetus of. How can
we engineer re engineer dunes
that have multi benefits
including infrastructure
protection for this really
practice. Connection between.
It's a need us in our-
subsidies. Infrastructure
protection- replacement of
historic ecosystem so it's
amazing I think we had our
first snow you clover- make a
nest there last year it didn't.
Last but the hope is that they
will learn that this is a place
where they can find rest. And
we even added. A improve our
coastal access with Gen walkway.
Highway and right to do even
though you're not a beach up
there still will to interact
with the ocean and able to
enjoy our coastal. And we added
four acres of this project so
that those and it's come a new
destination and a lot of ways-
so these are the images from
last Tuesday. It was six point
six tied we had lots of service
to. See start and to. Or if
roof and these photos were
taken caption there Giles- and
the middle one was taken of
Leucadia beat its grand view
and in Leucadia. No beaches the
only people there a go to the
beach that day were really if
Sir. To keep. These what steps
and jump off and get into the
ocean but beach access. I'm
this was taken on thinks. Is
also located. Side part of this
is just I'm size part that. We
have a local music will there
we host of events that the- AB
small businesses come together.
So it's all because of the
dedicated. That would be able
to turn this a park back into
apart from big back into a park
for surf top which is almost as.
If that had been etched. And
you'll see the in the
background you. A manual pumps
are still out there even. We
didn't get off the event it's
still challenge for us. I'm so
coastal region comes in a whole
bunch of different varieties
which means that we have to
react we have to message we
have to respond in. Many
different ways so you see that
photo the far left was a
discreet episode think happened
in just a moment. And as a mark
Gen there's vegetation that
have ice plant I can't any
other chronic inclusion but-
looks like it could have been
part of that feel in the middle
this is a case in US ongoing
stumping. Up doesn't. It. But
he really even talk to missus
isn't. That much of note and on
the right had a catastrophic
failure summers I think we all
still field believe me a lot
the lives of. Three shifts
community map. Dot thank.
Coastal phone- program in
ministry and dot person is like.
To you a couple of projects
that works about happening
right now in the city of
Encinitas. You have two minutes.
Okay I'll run through this I'm
Jamie to really come the some
program administrator for the
city best a which is funded and
by at a transient occupancy tax
that was established in
nineteen ninety eight through a
local proposition the program
and I are dedicated solely to
building coastal resilience and
facilitating beach restoration
projects through a phased out
of. Reach so what these-
efforts is the at St
compatibility which is to use
program or stoop we maintain
these per. Their federal and
state regulators permits which
help streamline the process
dean. And depositing high
quality compatible and low
volume amounts of San. You are
road beaches under the skew
program Sanders obtained
through opportunistic sources
which may include the goon in
the aging is my construction
basin maintenance or habitat
restoration projects.
Additionally the coastal
management program advocates
and coordinates with the army
corps of engineers and elected
state officials in pursuit a
fifty year and mostly federally
funded large beach nourishment
project. The coastal storm
damage reduction project as
it's called at plans to place
three hundred forty thousand
cubic yards of sand initially
and. Two hundred twenty
thousand cubic yards every five
years after that. For only be.
The product hills taking San
from for press. And place it in
a wide berm at the very bluff
through nine nourishment. I
from these types of nurse
projects ongoing scientific
studies form beach and bluff
management teams and help us
plan the dot for long term sea
level rise. Beats with and by
our bi annually state at least
across the whole city. And said
he's been perfect part of.
Highway one by both CLA and use
S. T. bluff management studies
are also currently underway we
are investigating the causes of
bluff failures as as they
relate to vegetation. The city
is C. to devise a bluff
vegetation management I'd with
the goal of providing. In
seizing. Guidance to private
residence and state parks on
how best to manage. Create less
vulnerable hazardous mission.
The city consistent studies
near Sharif's to ensure that
all out it's been cleaned
efforts are not negatively
affecting our offshore biota.
These studies specifically will
inform long term adaptation
solutions such as the creation
of artists to reefs. That could
facilitate San retention. Okay
I'm gonna get through it.
Thirty seconds oh my goodness
okay I'm gonna skip this one
but our highway has continued
to adopt as we have to become a
gathering. For people of. All
abilities all ages together
they're out of carbon- emitting
vehicles of X. on foot
strollers wheelchairs. That's
what our highways working often
hear some of our a new users we
didn't see a lot of those
before. This I could have on
one street scape and using Jack
that- trees question been
chopper rain water provide
access. Senate bill road to the
beach and then lastly how are
later can assist us. So we need
some Caltrans coordination with.
Right prior to our critical
infrastructure assets of the
family hold a goon is it ranks
highly- for their funding and
it should be because it's very
vulnerable we need help
eliminate access or beach the
PC no longer wants a permit
crossings but are the cheapest
sixteen usually forts we're
gonna need some help- under
crosses them and also we need
more collaboration between our
non regulatory agencies to help
our cities. And running before
having to act can't talk. I el
amendment. And then lastly
settlement and addresses you
know we find out that.
Sentiment trapped in our local
watersheds how do we get it
where it needs to be to the
beaches and not have to. Eat so
much for with private
developers to do that- so if
anybody wants to write a letter
to. The army corps that's a
contact info and that would be
helpful thank you. I love the
action orientation of the last
five. Yes thank you
councilmember cut. Almost like
thirds I wanna. Here I want to
thank assembly member about for
having us I think one of our
biggest challenges going
forward is to have this
collaboration any successful
solution was gonna bald us is I
can- and so any a mitigation
efforts we don't impact our
neighbors native. Negatively
gathered tele. I'm gonna steer
away from some macros just
focus on our unique challenge
Oceanside. And having an in for
us this a speculative issue.
Now and we need to take action
immediate I don't. Our to along
motions aye and what a what so
have the CEO of visit oceans
and. And as you brought up
earlier there are economic on.
Coastal provision could. Once
is our city so this first
picture it gives you a really
good over view she died and-
for those you were not aware we
are the third biggest city in
the county by population about
a hundred seven five was in the
of three to four miles. Three
miles across the street from.
Ten in our harbor as you can
see to. Carlsbad to this so it
but I cannot. West. We are a
public utilities and we have a
lot of our drivers are driven
by our beaches so we have. An
estimate we provide our beat
writer she provides about
hundred job. Room three hundred
fifty one million annual
visitors spending and twenty
two and state and local taxes
and a lot SB Joran and we have
a Venn super approach is it's a
fantastic event for us and-
I've taken my daughter there
several years and just
incredible for our- region
answer. That have a soccer term
at the beach so it is our
beaches are integral part our
state and mark successfully
hinges on. Other of our beaches.
So going through start for
north south we harbor it's your
unique to our being that starts
a camp Gen. Out of the Santa
Margarita river more work to.
But what finished as it does is
it stops function Santa support
from north south so with that
and mark the river. So my group
eight light tan post but at.
The pretty pictures most back.
Beaches are Beach until ten and
they want to be. When you
decide you can still get learn
more. So our check is open year.
The hopper dreads that's army
corps of engineers broad and
generally happens every spring
and you can see from the ocean
between the outer breakwater
their break water fills up a
sand from the law sure San
transport every spring and has.
Rights to get to the proper
depths. Product that is sand
that will. Which is but very
many it doesn't actually. Sir
be as much as we need so and
that's one of our main
challenges is you know how do
we get some at San from north
of the harbour to south no
water harbor does have- causes
its fair share of sand issues
it's also a great economic
driver as well so. It not only
does have the del Mar both
basin for K. Senate's although
almost a thou slip order a
harbor. Also regional asset
that is a fantastic place
whether you sail or even take
well watching it it's a great
opportunity we just need to.
Learn how to work with it and
get the sand around that I
that's been our- biggest
challenge. The north the south
we also miss our beach and
while. Maybe you to have as a
long wooden pier Wescott in
this kind of Morrell. S. a man
structures and for so as you go
of the south from the pier.
Your week we have a unique to
on our coast were. About a
hundred- a much for coastal
land was subdivided in plan for
resident no so we have streets
and houses up right on the
beach there protected by these
rock revetments. We don't have
a healthy each the way to go
into a commitments at the state
agency we're dealing with now.
Our best laid out as that.
Through on a healthy beach also
impacting those revetments at
home so this is a challenge
we've had for awhile but now
it's becoming extreme as you
can see in this picture. Close
that's our strand we club road
regularly during high tides and
when we have- more swelled the
normal. It's a challenge we're
already seeing damage to houses.
And those are we have about
five homes that we roughly a
dinner a dinner coastal hazards
vulnerability assessment. Five
hundred million dollar and
property value in million
dollars every year. And
residential property tax so
it's a it's a big on ports of
our city. Economic. Mmhm
success is down there it's
gonna be I was going forward to
address some of the houses that
are located there. I want to
go. On to conclude that's our
southern border which the it's
on these houses and very.
Portable how's but since I
found it three side by what so
they're gonna impact and his
rise or any stand. Which in the
end we are you check Gen oceans
I think. Really impacted are
the- I think I'm going back
this really illustrates this
picture is a great. Example of
shoes you see the sand stopping
north of the harbor and we
install it so. I don't know how
the left wing. This is this. Is
not in your twenty year this is
it she we're dealing with now
and it's could come in. We
address it and so we focused
the next fifteen to twenty
years you know that way we
don't the spec it. Out about
two feet of sea level Rafe. Yes
it's almost irrelevant we have
an issue to deal with
immediately and it's to be
Chao. We've. It numerous
letters army corps of engineers
asking for fees of study and
that's what on what can we do
with our endorsement. Impact
does the harbor have. Mission
promised in twenty twenty- get
put on the priorities so I can
tell you the good news the
sounds of the council
unanimously passed a step for
us go ahead and route in the
nourishment. Là via. She's we
have all our city were all work
in the right direction to get
those beaches help again but
it's going to be a challenge so
they also have our- principle
planner from the city rest
Cunningham who is kind lead the
move. City to. This fight what
the effects will be so again
for having us. Thank you. The
thank you very much for that I
appreciate you doing. Man it
really helps us understand the
similarities between the cities
and the difference. And now
mayor to Tina. Great I think I
have a present and I'm imperial
beach the stopping of the
county. Bob blue collar town
twenty thousand people third of
our kids live in poverty 25%
poverty rate. So really the
frame here is gonna be really
about equity. And really not
just about economic development
but about the development we
don't have. And the fact that
when we have flooded floods
cleaned or be on our streets
that means that's money were
taken away. From life are
problems and try to get a part.
Because we don't. We don't have.
Recently grocery store so we're
not there were some percent of.
Our. Living in Iraq hide your
pride making ends. Not just
about it in in poppy ride like
inch with trailer parks are
still tight you know it you you
see I hope. That's not the sort
of issue there were dressing on
a drug issue same and my pop he
is. Making sure that we can we
can carry out of for that are
still live in poverty and have
a great quality of life to send
your kids an insidious Russian
side or. Throughout southern
California how we're surrounded
on three sides. To start. Any
to wallow if you know straight
obviously. Rising that's going
to be end up. In my area there
is kids I'm. Might you know I
grew up in ivy my focus right
now isn't to still buys it make
sure to my can walk street not
by a car that's the issue right
like paving always were
crosswalks I am interested to
your leads back of unpaved
alleys right people were
because I can get to their
home. Was ending and thanks
we've been able heaving always
doing our rates are and you
know on the grocery store right
across all that reading a
trader Joe's real whole foods.
Grocery outlet that's what
works for our community the-
well for us right. And in
addition to the toxic waste in
storage at the club southern be
trait eight months right so we
are dealing all the new things
try to fight for community. In
dealing boxing is to bridge. As
our southern beach last year's
on is. Close right now so what
are your servers were. Big
waves the last week especially
the bay. Guys run the water.
Disclosed pollutant charts
rough level this is a state.
Feel state I surely this
because this is a reality on on
where the- I think is right.
It's gonna be shows dealers a
video which of you can press up
now yeah see. Thanks mark the
guys have been help. The
transcripts be John Gould has
lived in vero beach again for a
little over a year. He's
already gotten loose. It was my.
Sixteen high tide. They haven't
once or twice sorry. No that
was last year. Worse. I script
predicted that the light the
minute thank you mark. We were
we can is four days in advance
what really really hot on. So
anyway we actually carried out
on talking to twenty fifteen op
I think the California coast
commission California coast
Conservancy and are sending a
foundation I see the rise in
by. This and- but. The
supervisor base structure on so.
We found that on again impacts.
On throughout our community it
a total a lot Buck. A lot of
cost of ink on route the city
not just the west side of this
right by the ocean but on our
bay front. And identifying the
few flooding right this is
actually were built on the salt
flat rock Michael upland
habitat from. It back the day
was flooded right looks like
supposed to be I'm so what we
find about 40% of all roads
will be about. A Silverlight
rise 2110030% a part in
buildings arm and in. South.
Pretty so often and here I
think the forty three
different. Things we can do all
I took a hundred saw. Dr if we
only focused on manage retreat
and get mad the people don't
want to lose our homes and were
surprised that we see what
happened del Mar and ID. Then
we're going to spend the next
hundred years being at war with
the wealthy speak on the
planet. I'm not doing
allocation. I think what you're
seeing at the statewide level
and on and on the global level
as it was at the meditation
meeting in now to sign in in in
our in in April. Or may we have
people from all over the world
actually talking meditation is
they realize that if we're just
gonna get in a box about manage
retreat. With private property
owners we're not to preserve
our coast we've got to figure
out we've got to be a lot
smarter about how to do this.
And we got to broaden the scope
of what we do. Not talk about
the address but I'm we know we
know who paid for we know who
process obviously the client
the- fossil fuel industry so.
We were the first city world to
sue the fossil fuel industry
for causing surprise. It was.
My Richmond Santa Cruz. Carries
a separate tailing brand. All
older now by state of Rhode
Island to more. As the fact is
I think this is a big thing
legislators. We have zero money
to deal with this zero money
either want to pay my straight
to make sure that my kids have
a great quality of life kids
who live in poverty. Or I can
find the money from somewhere
and reality is we're gonna
figure this out for California
so on I wanna think scripts for
this our coastal monitoring
forecasting flooding model it's
brilliant it's genius. Loves
talk to scripted wrote
scientists on our beaches with
low they call. Taking a class.
And use it top world prop that
helps. Run flow. If your local
calls plan. Which is in about
as a regulatory box about
something that happened over
the next hundred years. All
right who has to deal with the
next hundred years right. If we
think it's been hot it is a
reason it's hard because we're
not we're not process been
built. To deal with for years
right we can over the next ten
minutes in the next ten years
but not on for years it's
complex stuff. Research figure.
Out park or because the plan to
deal with. Watashi. Destructive
right public the structure.
Republican for sure public
pressure that's our obligation
to address the construction
we're gonna. All natural
climate solutions restoration
right restoration restoration
restaurant. On the beach us
let's take the next better
could not test. On to be.
Should with natural ecosystems
we are so behind we've got to
be ahead of the curve and I've
talked to leaders Sacramento
the resource. God way Crofoot.
This we've got to be better on
this and- figure out how to
given agencies like the poor
the airport authority or send
act in Senate to question more
carbon. The enough for one the
solutions. And then maybe even
do offsets for it right and
then finally. Eight there's a
kid from the valley kids are to
make sure. This weather. Is
Sir. Where is it. When the
water could not be that's what
it is right right. I say manage.
What's happening or even I be
is to be expected if you come
up planned the says. It it's
will tell you that you might
have to move out your houses in
three years of course people
get upset we should expect. We
have to be smarter about how we
do this I saw presentation by
mark called is that the ocean
protection council I think
folks in Sacramento we're
talking climate bond are really
thinking strategically about
this and saying if we get
sucked in. To adults with
private you know the wealthiest
people on the planet. We're
not. Storm protect the entire
California coastline blocking.
For well as assembly hold a gun
and- we think stand for billing
project assembly hall. Hello
talk about it. But that's we
have to focus on these. Big
picture. Public infrastructure
protecting our beaches right.
On restore our natural
wetlands. And doing those
things robin just. Spending 99%
of our time doc. But private
property. Just cried since this
battle that. Districts a losers
that set the other day Hey we
always wanted on the beach
right so thank you very much.
What's but no less from my age
to Dana thank you so much for
really at addressing the
elephant that I think is in the
room. How do you really talk
matter that Tatian when there's
conflict involved. In the
interest of time running about
five minutes behind we're gonna
move straight to the next panel
of the so I hope for. Our panel
will- of to limit centers. Will
remove. No solutions to see
level right we have Jacob Gould
single senior legal counsel for
in north county transit
district. Calling plans for the
director of regional planning.
And ag I think once a few words
welcome to join us branded read
director of planning of fail us
for this vehicle county
regional airport authority as
well as Eileen mayor- direct.
Environmental conservation for
the port. Wait intro to the
next panel because he mentioned
I think half of the agencies
are all the agencies that are
going to be presenting so we
can go ahead and start with
Jacob. Would you like to make
some introductory comments.
Thank you very much- glad to
see you by the way don't tell.
I felt that the five. Have I
appreciate being here at this
hearing I've been here for a
year. I am bay area I seen how
close the track to the beach.
And I can tell you that. If you
think about it. Let's say god
forbid operations stop. We
could read out passengers what
to do with freight 10% of old
many fact card was so LA law.
Mr Donahue but one with Christ
said the LA a Long Beach we
said we need the state to help
and we get to a bond be money.
To build goods moment the first
Sector-Limón Senate that that
very well. We need the same
level here. I promise you it's
Sunday. We are gonna once and
for all. Official to do
immediate things we did- thank
god for the civilization that I
would engineers that either way
what happened. To the to go
with the- this Senate that I
can get this from the not say
yes to six million dollars to
design the next phase that's
the belies ation. We need
eighty nine million dollars. To
quote design construct.
Civilization five five six
that's immediate that's a
safety issue. We should not the
bill. We should figure out what
get the money we should do it.
Long. And I appreciate Medina
said look then we have to. Face
up to the fact that political
solution is not get. It's not
cheap. It's gonna và moving
the fax Ellen is gonna involved
and a lot of if structure work
that were not used to and it's
gonna cost in the billions. Of
the millions. And I promise you
I met to you that in eighteen
months. You will see the
solutions in the table on I
told you a some of that. Going
to be any discussion partisan
discussion for leaders to
difficult Sir gonna here today
from Colleen about specific
things as he level rise and
other things we were doing the
five big moves. I think we're
leading the country acted in
how we think about the future
in a press to the class
provisional sustainability so
with that thought then. The
final. Thank you. Members of
the- and I'm thank you Hassan
for the introduction and I
think this- actually the way we
are thinking about this fits in
really well for what am heard
from I'm doctor Merrifield
about it the key. Mitch
sealevel rise as a result of
that and so one of the things
that we're working on it see an
bag is putting a bold new
transfer. Vision to really
fundamentally change how people
get around region have a real
true transportation option
driving up on so this right
away that are greenhouse gas
emissions is what the big
moves. All of what can we
please but or take the whole
concept of come street. All of
our made record is in the
reached. At every. Door we have
managed and we have a speech
and Mike and Pat a lot of we
are team now that is
constructed in the five.
Because. North train we can and
to the next level. But the
eighty ninety eight mile our
that would be compact. With
dropping mobile the heads of
the centers act. Get after.
Highs in transit networks to
the smaller nay. Get mobility
hub and throughout our
community and an operator
system that's what we call the
bring to this team that's the
technology we have all the
information to help us make the
best transportation choice in
terms of time and be able to
pay for that right on our own.
New we're doing in this
planning in addition to this-
also the G. is using data to
help in more. Ways. Pretty
project. Will help move the dot
in read greenhouse gas
emissions starting just where
people work. Reach and where
they live this figure. Where
where is along the coast which
is important climate of all
right well dark. So the Boston
populated area. Read and then
on where people work these are
the appointment setters in our
region and when you bring them
together there really all with
the same part of the India
region in the western third. At
the one block me depressed and
fully. It. Now can we call our
our figure eight we have a full
connected high speed internet
now that's also ported I. Can
hi be met lanes hi stem that
this will port its movement in
there HM. Our poll thing and-
well highs transistor trip
travel option. And looking
brighter begins to much of what
is really focus. On what. Can
bill you look this coach I
think about each and were able
to. More than. Read the import
opportunity one we can start
and development in the what the
region. Not fall out it opens.
It is a miles trout direct
relation with greenhouse gas
emissions but also we can take
advantage of the carbon
sequestration through
preserving our open space as
the- well Beach mentioned it's
also important to look at
though most of our growth all
of our infrastructure is in
the- areas. So this is the area
where we're going to be making
the greatest investments in the
transportation network and need
to be thinking about the
resiliency and how we plan for
these. Light of sea level rise-
we've all seen the effects-
this is just one example one on
Taiwan a at it. This think is.
Action kind of similar we see
each that were having to
address this up for regular
basis of course what happened
over the weekend where what
we're we're dealing with is a
many right off and rainy this
step. That we toured as- well
as- on blast so it's from both
aspects with more violent
storms that we have to be
thinking about all of this in
collaboration with local
jurisdictions in this region
and so we have eighteen cities
one county ten local jerks ten
cities- our have our along the
coast the county is a small
piece but literally every. Be
with Israel Gen as is packed I
see level right even down to
those areas river valleys all
of these are areas that are a
half this is the more at risk
thank debt income ratio our
local state Senate's the fight
the way we but or- to become.
North south is. In right so
this is San Diego. But if you
look at this is. Here are give
me my five I. Feet of sea level
rise that said the top front
groups talked about. You can
help me that I'd with below in
the red line with. Five at and
the trolley these are made the
court or as transportation
infrastructure in this region
and while we a lot of help the
black the Coast. Can anyone
there are big impacts also in
south county Coronado strand
you see these yellow areas
these are the it is the are
greatly. Impacted by two and a
half feet. A seat all right and
that shows that. Six point.
Eight in level so it is up and
down the coast there are major
at the a issues associated with
all yes. Well at Xin strip
tease possible Jennifer there's
a drip with everything from
knowing. When to close on the
street from the brace back. Now
we do are you made in for sure
in men's exam that. We can
continue to do that the repair
work to stabilize the bluffs in
the Los and corridor while we
are planning for an approach is
a sign mentioned actually move
that trade corridor further
east out of them less
vulnerable areas. The Los and
corridor think everyone here
this is the second is interest.
L. but or a nation. Ask a day
third out in. You're about
billion in moved and something
that we can forget about is
portal to the F. early doesn't
the rock for it and access
which has a door in our and our
region and the economy of our
region so just to kind of wrap
up we talked about the bluffs
it's veto. It the right from up
above. Well at. The door upset
he wrote in the black from that
blow. Also bridges and other
infrastructure that help the
poor the quarter this is the
bridge today just imagine. Beat
of sea level rise- six feet you
see right away what that would
do in this is major of that
order so we just want to wrap
up by saying this region is
ready to work together to hold
multiple work efforts at local
Jr. Done a deep level it really
does take a regional approach
we can expect the city of
imperial beach to be
addressing- you know sea level
rise on their own or Encinitas
or del Mar Coronado it impacts
the airport the port of San
Diego in all of us and I think
working together is an
important piece we are
extremely appreciative of the-
funding that we receive from
senator Atkins. To really start
some of the work in the you
don't continue the work on the
low side corridor there's a lot
more to do replying federal
grant we are looking at every
opportunity to secure funding
to help make this region as
resilient as possible under the
circumstances will. Also plan.
Reduce. With that I'll turn it
over to my friend here from NC
TV. Good afternoon- my name is
taken goal from NCTE filling in
here for our chair Tony Krantz
he's been under the weather-
original presentation was just
gonna be a half hour of that
bluff slipping. From Delmar.
Will save you the terror that
we've been in during for that-
NCG as a transportation agency-
for years under seventeen oh
three. A lot of the region
employer Xin of the checks was
transferred over standard ****
love stabilization we work
closely with stand on that but
the operation the date a- that
is what in see TV does. We have
really two sides the coin we
have our infrastructure that we
operate on and we have the
vehicles that operate within on
that infrastructure- we have
transitioned are breeze fleet
which is our bus fleet- almost
entirely from diesel to.
Natural gas- right now we have
a total fleet will out of a
hundred fifty vehicles nine of
those are CNG and so were I are
diesel the rest are CNG were
making that move towards a
cleaner- fleet there. Are we
have currently on order were re
looking to replace our seven
locomotives which are currently
tears zero we've had those
since inception- those are.
Moving up we're very shortly
are on order to our tear for a
clean diesel. Electric
locomotives so on the G. G.
application for Viçt that's
were removing all of it takes a
tremendous amount. In into the
buses off million dollars
locomotives I can imagine is
quite a bit more than that- to
do those rations- it takes
money that obviously we don't
collect from any of our
writers- we rely on the state
and the federal government for
a lot of those grant.
Application. Our backup
generators for all of this is
to make sure that if the power
goes out we can still operate
trans for those that need it
some people that's the only way
that they can get around-
looking into that to see what
we can do in corporate in green
infrastructure in our capital
projects that we actually
implement so that we can do
that in a sustainable manner.
Dream is a huge issue along the
entire right away- with a lot
of the cities where we operate-
nobody wants to see it and we-
came. In for deep purple for a
bus to come. With ME delayed
for half an hour because the
track you can see what the-
it's like when it. When it's
been raining for more. Twenty
minutes. To meet these within
the corridor were implemented.
We Santa gone for capital
project temptation. Bridge
replacement from a hundred year
old timber to deal in. That of
that the potential- flood any
access so that when it does. X.
are and then the one that is
obviously on every his mind is
our bluff stabilization- what
are we doing for that we've had
we're currently- marble for
stable to project- blood
stabilization project five is
actually push for were asked
for additional money from the
state on an emergency basis to
go under in a W. W. engine. To
use the tional. Have inspectors
out there twenty four seven
we've got crews out there.
Water situation is really saw a
lot of things happening you saw
the picture of the whole.
Keynote two feet from the
track- there are piles in a lot
of the block that are keeping
that up so there's no immediate
driven balling in. Tuition I'm
what is the economic loss
should something catastrophic
happened- we can't calculate
the entirety of that economic
loss in terms of freight good-
of all. Else but just the
replacement cost if the rail
were to be taken out you take
out a two hundred foot section.
Just replace that is about
three hundred ten million
dollars over a year almost nine
hundred thousand dollars a day
just to re route traffic to put
all that freight onto a truck
and put it on I five to get.
People on the bus bridges they
can get to work that does not
take into account. Travel does
not take into account the value
goods there moved in that right
which is quite a significant
impact on that. Again there.
The needed secured within that
rely uber tell patients run in
there that's not in there if
that cut we losing from we
lose. Lose a so it is a big
deal- what we are asking the
state and the federal
government and grant
applications we have- to their
open right now- I know for del
Mar bluffs five I think- that
one is out for about thirty
billion dollars. As the sun
said it's probably closer to
ninety to get the thing done-
and that is not. In our next
year that's a long term of. A
long term item. So this one's
going to be with us for a while
we're looking for solutions to
that and as my executive
director would say show me the
money. A five we have money to
do it will do it. The biggest
interested bring that together.
Good afternoon I first want to
thank the chair for inviting
already to participate in this
important discussion today. My
name is Brandon read on the- I
will fairs at the airport-
before joining their fourteen
years ago actually was the city
to list as climate medic
adaptation met. From the circle
for. Really not too shocking to
say that airports are
incredibly important
transportation asset when
you're looking at the
California county or even the
San Diego economy last year our
airports International Airport
twenty million passenger. About
a hundred thousand tons of move
through the can that can help
contribute to the airports
annual economic benefit to the
region about twelve billion
dollars. I in this map- on the
display shows it's black that
is a five passed yours. I think
it's just a great weather are
you are a business our resident
or visitor comments to break go
spur. Bear serves at. The key
to this region worse than all
the act make. Connected with
that. I'm I'm a little more
optimistic it's just my nature
about one thing I wanted to
note is that- sea level rise is
something we've actually been
thinking about for awhile in
this region in twenty twelve
all the jurisdictions are on
the air the cynical baking
together enveloped a joint
level rise out of two. Strategy
twelve. The wild wild west
prime an adaptation no. Think
about it. And this is really
one of the first studies like
this that happened in the
nation so we had some really
great momentum that I wanted to
recognize. Of airport authority
of the last year's formalized
our- strategies if you will-
more- with our resilience plan.
Where we look at the airports
expo. She loves ice precipitate
change and ting he- through.
The century and then I did some
quantifiable. Sure that are
doing we need to do to be more
recipients. So to sum it maps
maps are thing we can about. At
this age. Before I get to the
mall going that help to warm up
AB T. strategy he's just.
Federal. The fate we have run
away see that it down the
middle. The river. Going north.
The north we have a target. If
but he's an- users axe them I'm-
Washington Street. One thing
that people don't always
realize that we actually aren't
right on the water we have
others between us in the water
line- and we have a locked so
starting on our southeast
corner this is actually US
Coast Guard. Station. We harbor
on which the poor S. and
Esther's on our- own through
have the same. Property. Fourth
we have the marine corps with
deep so I can't stress enough
that regional solutions
collaborative approaches for us
it's a must because we can do
everything on site we can but
if we're not working with the
port in the city and other. As
a really help us at the end of
the day. So this is just these
are just some maps that we've
done using cost us which is a
of off the shelf Bob playing
of. Twenty hundred. At the blue
is. Flooding can adjust the
level rises. Those store one
your form of. So if in twenty
for the you know I see some
storm surge flooding along with
harbor I've she is the an
animal. At point to the airport
and on the- very. Our we
hundred and if center building
again we cease storm surge
really creating most of the
flooding pattern at those two
corners well of are pretty.
When we go to a more extreme C.
là press the five. Billion I'm
you can. The map start. Mark I
didn't see much more serious
now along the entire harbor
five. This group Steve Kerr
water. And we have more
distance thing. On west side of
our can't as well. They're
actually deliver. Five if you
can. If you go on line down you
know the- factors for the level
rise in store which actually
would look worse. Of those who
fled. Anymore since the cut out
a with. We actually. There are
very airport and I'm bringing
up only because fought for
actions today. Really can have
a big impact in twenty one
hooked. And Fuller close but we
didn't make those changes that
I just highlighted with sea
level rise in mind your we're
fixing drainage issues we're
just preparing the site for
construction so just imagine
what we can do when we have
this information to inform.
That design of a new terminal
for say. Little optimism. So I
wanted and just with that sort
of some observations and
lessons learned from the
airports experience. I'm one
again as I think now is time
to. Create resilient is in the
sciences forever changing and
is rates up have to use the
better for me we have how to.
Is this our how infrastructure
this transfer in infrastructure
that's- to our economy. A big
part of what we found is really
the need for more granular data
that's C. là eyes and rural
but also pride like data I've
would have just use the our
shop you will thousand model.
Of thanks. But again we had our
in our day and so we have a
seat see we are a little bit
better shape another thing I
just would point out where
working with doctor merry feels
group at scripts and the port
of San Diego to deploy a
network of sea level rise
centers in San Diego bay to
figure out how does that storm
surge which really is actually
probably the most impactful
part of all of the all these
impacts how does that work in a
semi closed embayment as
opposed to an open coastline so
that'll really help us define.
Those models. And then I can
see at the airport we're
embedding climate resilience
you can climb at TI in toward
the making system. So. Every
little prop and jet he was
ending for the team and we
don't give a **** this point.
Documents you know and for the
feet four feet we taped thing
the best a double. Time because
it's get involving prop yes
point it at its a critical part
of our decision making process.
And then I just want to point
out another thing out of this
little study from twenty twelve.
The jurisdictions around the
table that work on a real as
well it really helps when sort
of the on the ground practice
get together. I'm sure lessons
learned. And Richard is and
through this this is one of the
impetus for creating the sandy
regional climate collaborative.
I'm and now there are similar
collaborative all across the
state- so just one highlighted
those type of. Forms where
academia comes together with
non profit business and public
agencies because this is
certainly an all hands on deck
kind of problem. With that I
thank you for your time thank
you. Yeah great. Yeah my name's
I call her and I'm with. The
director Barbara county chin
and I also see are aquaculture
bluetec program and I mention
that because it will be talking
about- what mayor dina doctor
about and some of our- since
two sealevel rise that were
working on so. The poor you
probably pass along harbor
drive going to the airport when
you're going to and from your
thanksgiving vacation- but we
are San Diego bay we have see.
Sec about six thousand acres
around San Diego bay that we
are the trustee for the state
of California to manage those
resources. We have about twenty
two public park so come on down
to visit I'm more than happy to
the- we. Bob yes our water is.
Bogart. And of course public
and one TV along. As it. The
islands around twenty eight
thank Montel were first
fisheries navigation wrecked
environmental stewardship. It's
called the penny this is. We
also regularly including
coastal act the port act in a
lot of weeds under. Assembly
six one. Which required us to
look at our bone ability for
sea level rise. We have a lot
of plans and policy center on
our website it good night time
reading there we by you to take
a look bad. Assembly bill six
the what was. Specifically to
force. Impacts kilo right look
at to fix he will rise time Ms
refining telling to be of. Talk
steak burgers and work them to
answer questions that court
that was due last year.
Whenever AB adaptation policies
and we have me I. This is a
example you have to use both
kids but we also looking living
or lines up that. It has in
Marin only for. Tional but
lends. I mean things I an
instruction. Step back to be a
to accommodate. Of all right.
So the port is also a large
partner with the US navy- we've
been partnering them for
decades starting with our
integrated natural resources
management plan which is only
joint dot in the country and we
also have. A random. With the
V. eight ten the only be I'm-
agree this the next three with
AB. And local group so
basically we're nay on the
level rise and coast leading
the bay. I wanted to. Mention
as Brandon mention are- wave
monitoring pilot project with
scripts. And I'm personal. A
lot of the work that hearing of.
If you the rest of ones that
will help. At sealevel rise.
Trees planted in. Three but
when an acting nine will have
that's. So not only does it
have with all right here
question Gen for both wetland
in yoga. I'm sick to bay has
about fifty in person the bill
in the state. I'm a. That the
three is more. Than forest's
general so. Eight eight two one
six working on health under
section couple years is for us
in the bay are clueless the
city beach on the right and a
city of Saint go on left. And
that is a former stock pond we
want store to. Well let at a-
meeting bang- in the fun from
that mitigation bank with. The
local community with
infrastructure and jobs. In we
started during current studies
as we think this restoration
for creating a ticket thank you
be about an 89% by your to one
hundred. Big see. That part
because when that price for it
if. We also have a cut in to be.
Up. To clean we see this. So
here's the part Leo I will que
sure. Growing see we of
cleaning up the mess in the a
and a couple of projects that
all dive into you. I'm. No pan
into some guys dive. Do you
like three D. can for as a.
Using kelp kelp into
corporation well we they to
feed water. Gallons a day an
instant also there's also carp.
The we are pop culture call one
eight three I am. The company
that working their cell to
arrest. The thing rips apple
Charlie. Were hurt can hope
that. May make. A rap but also
make pool in missional at which
will so. At Easter and also
help with currency question in.
Conclusion we're seeing a lot
of work- to resources habitat
restoration mitigation banking-
in innovative technology clean
aquaculture to you with carbon
seek patient all help with reap
billions. So thank you. Thank
is somehow back on track on
time so I'm sure that do you
have any questions from our
member legislators before we go
into public. Ten questions. And
in the coastal protection and I
wondered what is the number
there how much money are are
you able to just from your own
efforts are put forward towards
your plan. Gives us an idea of
what additional money we need
it be opting for no like men
that matching funds and things
like that that. Are certainly.
Available we if we can show
that the communities to see
these are doing a lot on their
own- the state needs to step in
and I think it also helps with
a federal. Matching funds just
like it does for transportation.
I'm so I can answer that over
the past two years we've
accumulated- about five hundred
thousand. Dollars in the tier
to find in August two coastal
zone management. I just I just
like to put that out there for
discussion when we get back to
Sacramento that. When you
cities that are stepping up to
address this and there are. No
the loan- Indians out there
trying to you know support and
protect their immunities that
we should be first and foremost
to advocate for them at the
state. All to do a matching
funds sort of program in our
budget. With the fat with our
federal representatives also
because it is you know it's
kind of show me the money for a
lot of these projects that are
very very important. So I just
like to note that but
congratulations I think when
you get a local tax past that
connects directly to something.
An official odd to your
community the buyer whatever.
We have a lot of support from
president. Those of us who are
at. No tax an orange get went
to hell in a house the house on
those we had to fight to get
him to pass. For our- roads
budget Aston south. Tell them
to support completely to help
us and match us. Thank you
other. Thank you madam chair
one of all the presenters- it's
a luxury that we don't get to
have a more in session hello
the latest for a long time here
from all different perspectives
of says the I said. Get
everyone giving us so much of
apple Tom. Start with the most
urgent to terms the dhamma
blasts and out of San data into
T. wants to address this- but
the funding that senator Atkins
was able to secure in this
year's budget- I. Was on I
think I heard you say that will
have- since our deliverable in
next year or so have the
desire. For a. The civilization
five we need. Money to
construct the actual piles and
you get a number for what
eighteen million dollars two
five and six design and build
an engine that would be like
most projects a blend of local
state federal funding of some
club and that would be very
happy to. Local funding into.
We have the state and if it
comes in not to hold you. For a
specific figure today but a
ballpark figure of what that be
from a state perspective eighty
nine million a. But that is why
he's very good at what he got.
The you can get then I
appreciate. Willing to discuss
this to the state level any
money can we get to just simply
do five and six to realize
issue. At four twelve avoid. It
will it will be much you have
to look at the longer term
solution that will cost more. I
think you have issue saying out
of forum. For the server. For
this plan is on the table at
again assemblymember hard
discussing a lot of the citing
issues there and you do not be
shy minister how can put this
issue obviously in a center at.
People engaged. This is urgent
and you are your your comment.
Above for both agencies-
illustrate this isn't just an
inconvenience not of couple
commuters on the coaster that's
going to be inconvenient so
that would mean to me by
itself. This is truly could be
catastrophic our economy. Not
just locally before nation and
I want act accordingly and show
the kind of urgency from the
state level that. Is
appropriate for the service
without committee you. She
needs of ends up parts of the
state so- thank you again at.
Coming out of I just want to.
Amplify that the words of you
know did a great job of. Begin
to something that this has been
a few of the seemingly zero sum
game in when we when we buy
into that kind of. That I mean
nothing gets done and if I
think all in this room this
afternoon because you believe
this is an urgent issue. And
any sort of still meeting of it
is not beneficial I appreciate
you. Taking the number things
we can do- that there is broad
consensus forecast what senator
Bates is getting to a moment
ago- and I would urge that
continued focus on on those
kinds of issues- informed as to
what we can do and I think.
Many in this room I know not
everyone may realize. The to a
year where- you know we collect
legislative ideas and figure
out priorities to address in
it- and so. This is the perfect
time to say you know Hey this
not that. This week here this
repeal their this internet
legislation here- these are
often while we hope these
hearings at this time of year
and stuff. That I think of AB
wonder leave your one me what
should come next immediate we-
should be in contact with any
of our offices saying. You know
here's a legislative idea this
year is a budget ask for the
coming year. Or his image to
repeat because it just doesn't
work anymore- in the context
of. Changing sea level rise so.
I just put that general plea
out. And then lastly of doctor
Merrifield still here I think
he has. A you you kind of put
it. Last by which I. Because
role that deliverables right a
lot of this is information
coming and it's fantastic but
really. What can we do and ms
Barnhart I. Took note of that.
A substantial reduction in
carbon emissions- maybe just.
Of a moment at the microphone
of what you might actually.
Suggest we do I think we have
some notions their bills up for
around in the legislature. Some
have been successful some have
not been. From your person from
your position in the
professional. Background what
would you like to see the state
of California due to actually
speak to that. Bullet point it
is one one one one long but-
what it. There's a lot I think
we're at the point where. We
appreciate we see because my we
appreciate. In the. I'm really
planning hi it doesn't quite
have the detail we need for our
sort of like- going forward in
the ten twenty her oxen
thinking about what we need to
do now ice on these adaptive
pathways stop steps so I'm I'm
really in favor of expanding
what we did in. Beach more
communities along the coast to
build in this resilient-
infrastructure standing for in
for predicting and for a going
forward and I think more
projects like that would really
help community. Well we are so
fortunate scripts here in San
Diego I know you were because
beyond just our our county
limits will grateful that
you're here. Thank you
Esperanza shall follow up on
that real quick if you wouldn't
mind- specifically when you
said aggressive reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions what
were the fob top five things
California can do. Next year.
To achieve that bullet point. I
think for California one two
three four and five is
transportation I mean I thought
the send a presentation was
right on point. We have to bill
communities were doing or what
were we doing much traveling
between. Where we working where
we live. I was I thought the
vision. Keeper for was system
that we can reach that. But
that's that's the future I
think for California. Yeah I
think there's some. I. I think
that we can do a southern cal
legislators of collective. And
it is we talk about cabin trade
funnies pictures California
their fair share we have been
receiving our fair share now
typically transportation
dollars are are are dealt out
on a population basis or rap
based on your population those
are. Let's go up in a pretty
fair fashion but the cap and
trade has not so something we
need to talk about as a
southern California delegation
going to this next year is how
do we get our fair share of cap
and trade. A to address in
nexus between the purpose of
having trading right and what
the ultimately use her. Can I
give you an example this last
budget. There's a hundred
million dollars- from cabinetry
on ongoing committed on an
ongoing basis to the Central
Valley. To provide clean water.
For there's no nexus between
the purpose of the cap and
trade dollars and clean water
doesn't mean that clean water
is not needed. But that's
really a general fund
expenditure that should not be
a cap and trade expenditure
that the legislature- committed
to so those are the kinds of
dynamics that we could walk.
Watch for as we head into next
year fair share and making sure
that the dollars are spent. In
a- fashion. Did you have a
specific thing sure. Following
climate change since nineteen
ninety nine when I did a face
some climate change could you
please identify yourself yes I
I'm Christopher those don't
know I mean I work with
sandbags. I live in dolma. I'm
I've been. Interesting climate
change since the nineteen
eighties when I read an article
in Scientific American that
alerted me to the sea level
rise. Only the thesis on the
subject in nineteen eighty
nine. But what I've seen in the
trenches here over the last
twenty years working in seated
in San Diego. Easily get money.
For checks that. Improve the
capacity of a transportation
system. What's very difficult
is it meant. For resiliency.
And as we soaring Collins
presentation the bridge St
Peter. With six feet a syllable
rise will be at the top of that
bridge. But it's very hard to
get the money to replace that
bridge because- it doesn't
qualify as a capacity enhancing
project. It's an old bridge.
That is not resilient. And said
my appeal to you as a group of
that. This is trying to make
some. Money available for
transportation resiliency. As
opposed to always saying you
have to increase service so you
have to. In a move more people
we can't move any painful if
the bridges on the war. Well
the bluffs files a. Many for
resistance is might flee. Thank
you. Thank you. I wanna I wanna
thank everybody removed public
comment of them. You know when
we get that impact. That
assembly member Gloria was
talking about for justifying
the del Mar blast. I think one
number that I see clearly from
today's presentation hopefully
all took that with the two. Is
the impact and goods and
services it would be if the del
Mar blasts. Not available are
the dump the. To the del Mar is
not available so you know if we
if you that number please share
with us now but otherwise the
idea right now but we have the
economic impact. Of goods
movement in the region we can
make that inviolable to. Hey
guests thing is to be with us
today talking about how do we
preserve what's wonderful about
our coastline. But really faced
allergies of the next hundred
years and level right. Arm you
know I a one I think all the
agencies that are here today I
want to thank my team. Cecilia
Montez my legislative director
she is a veteran of the
building and I she was the one
who is primarily responsible
this so let's give the some
jazz hands Visalia. With
Claudia Espinoza from my team
we have Alex he won my district
director heather Conklin is
somewhere my chief of staff rob
Charles a somewhere Fernando is
the- you know he's actually
feel right for Mister- and our
fifth wheel right for Oceanside
but he actually with. The V.
today's a good job in and out-
and so made it all work I
wasn't really clear about that-
it when I when I pull this all
together. What I hear is four
main things. We need to pursue
pursuit aggressive reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions. And
that means it's gonna be a
change in our way of life. And
changing aye. Cations first
many years changes so hard for
folks except. But if we want a
planet for our children we're
just going to embrace it. And
waste well through it together
I really. Appreciate surge
dina. Caught let's get away
from talking and retreat and
talk about what are the
adaptation strategies we can
agree on- because with our
science is changing so much.
You know the second thing is I
heard was. The more Deventer if
it data driven modeling and I
think what we've heard of
scripts is doing a really great
job we have spending for
resiliency. I think what I want
to thank the port and the
airport authority in sand act
and see TV I know you guys are
on the frontline of this and I
really think the airport a
thought for how you present in
it and she but it's possible-
to plan for it- the last thing
is- our second to last two
things- we do need to move to
action. Some of the actions for
funding some of that action is
policies- echo the sentiments
assembly member Gloria now is
the time we're putting together
our build cages budget asks
this is when we need to come
together- do like I really
pushed under Bates about asking
funds- cities who are
committing and putting. Their
get in the game let's see what
how can help them I think we
see coastal cities when this
arm know that every he has the
capacity so how do we have the
equity component in it- and I
do see Coronado and AB are
probably really on the
frontline what we're gonna do.
And I really urge you are any
five and you have to fight
traffic. Down or we can go have
dinner. Make a little. Later
and so when we look at this. We
have a- board together this is
the first of many hearings. I
think it's really important
we're starting here we're gonna
do them throughout the state.
She keeps I want to take of an.
We do things assembly touched
up but up her feet here looked
at. An thank you assemblymember
are owed being here we heard
that Long Beach is already been
experience as we know we saw
those maps about Ventura thing
in the bay area we know this is
how. Eight and we moving
forward that said we have
fifteen minutes. Want to public
comment you can line up if
they're more than fifteen
people you get thirty seconds
if there's less than fifty
people you get a minute. So
please calm line up for public
comment. As we do have to and
five I'm sorry. Serve only five
people line up you each get
three minutes. Going now.
There's people lined up you get
five minutes is all works. I'll
try to be brief okay thank you
so much for your name for the
record. Look I live in Cardiff.
Not on the beach. Access. Some
comments on some things that
were said today in the last
month and things were said to
the- and- treat is never going
to. The Xin is gonna take far
longer than I have. I was
suggested legislature get the
coastal commission off that
page. Suggest that you look at
other areas of the country not
and also in Europe. I grew up
in New England where they've
been fighting. Coastal erosion
for over a hundred fifty years
in winning. At any of that
stuff here and I think we need
to look outside of California
for some answers- I used to
take the closer to work in
downtown San Diego stopped.
Partly because he took an hour
and a half extra than driving.
And also up in that bluff is
scared of these a salary I was
in government and
transportation for forty odd
years. Looking at subway
systems around the world. I
would. Get off the bluffs fast
as possible not miles inland
because it that's what we're.
Cutting over of one a one three
del Mar. The be inconvenient
for. But that's house somewhere
well to Boston. Bill Tom. Right
now I'm- right wing more
earthquakes and we do. It's you
know something needs to be done
now- I've noticed in the
standard budget there's been no
money even the study some of
the stuff for the last five
years I suggest that. Thank you
final. In is something that was
only mentioned I also lived in
the Pacific Northwest. Oregon
Washington and British coal all
have. Marked he wished includes.
Because to not to do have king
tides to have. I seen one sign
in California. Is the holy
shores at the beach. And then
it doesn't tell you where to go
it just says evacuation. This
evacuation routes effective.
Are clearly marked are free of
impediments. And even having in
washing safer volcanoes. As you
a mountaineers their. The
obvious choice for your like
Leucadia and other parts of its
a need just up and down the
coast. What used to be one of.
Nothing was state the state
dropped no one is a highway.
Because if anything happens and
I five you have no back up.
Living in Washington where a
truck damage to bridge for six
months. And they had to go on
ninety nine which is equivalent
up there. We don't have that
back up. One on one would be
the evacuation route strips
gaping it's going to kill
people. If you look at the
paradise fire. When the main
says of death. According to the
LA times poll. Is that they'd
street scape the main. Have any
out of the town. People are
trapped in their cars. We can't
afford that here we need to be
respectful for everyone and not
for the convenience of a few.
Thank you thank you so much you
have two minutes. Good
afternoon thank you so much for
hosting this a hearing was very
informative and Tara I know I
appreciate that my name sherry
mac and former council member
for the city of Oceanside
Oceanside resident in here
today representing the citizens.
Of the press parks and beaches
something that is very dear to
our. What I if at all possible
I've been to several hearings
and if you're here it's great
you can absorb the information.
However if you're not here
trying to track down. The data
the power point presentations
all that great information you
have to go to each agency and
Hutton pack what are the
possible that you could
consider having a link to all
the information that present.
Possibly on Facebook page so
that'd make it easy for the
public. Said just said it will
be on my website awesome I
thank you so much. Hello my
name my. Charlie McDermott
insists for. I want to raise
two points of a start some
macro points the drill down to
something that's that's really
critical particularly for
Anthony this. No California's
very blessed we have. Probably
mild climate compared to let's
say New Hampshire we don't have
ice storms we don't have to re
pave the roads every three
years- and we also have a
massive tax base to hear
there's no money the money
there's no money the state has
extremely high taxes. And
there's potentially no
meaningful infrastructure
spending the state for near the
century the greatest. Leucadia
should not be flooding that's
not sea level rise that's a
rain storm and if you look at
the data that was presented
today. We haven't even headed
to the point of significant sea
level rise. We are just
reaping. The seeds that we so
inaction in maintaining
reasonable infastructure for
first will country Nicaragua
has better drainage to locate a.
And I think the issue to me is
getting. Is caught up day to
some of these very pressing
issues. Which are very glad
that was shown that's coastal
erosion that's a massive
collapse at a public beach
where people and kids play in
senators didn't lose three
people at loss for people in
the last ten years. And I live
right in the KDE. That blood is
full time I am shocked we four
people have been killed. And
what I recommend is. You guys
have to support these now you
have to at least I'll property
owners to support their
property with homes. And see
walls and drainage. Or whatever
it needs to be done instead of
a tax. Threatening them having
a life guard spying take
pictures because you've been
guided by. Rather. Problems
playing box falling you killing
people on the beach this is
happening now and it's going to
happen and I just went out
there yesterday I saw about
five hundred pound chunk that
didn't come to wave action is
because rainstorm and it fell
down so I recommend private
property owners be allowed to
responsibly manage their boss
without being attacked is right
now no one's touching anything.
And I think the access points
do you think they should have
more action concert. Tragedy in
the light stamp right in front
of the very small seat. This
the safe. Going here he has put
rocks in front read that it
stands you will not while
private property up to do right
behind the massive retaining
wall. From falling into the
back of this. And round here
anyone else because if you have
a vertical near vertical slope
and you're a lot of rain you
could have a revision and then
you get have collapsed. Think
if he thank you. Hi assembly
member for vested in in Gloria
in or visiting members I'm
Francine but as bay I am a-
proud of the president of card
by the sea for thirty years and
I'm here representing
congressman là. So I want to
end on a high note I have to
say we have a congressman who's
working very closely with. Sam
Derek with cities and- please
he has worked. At the our our
Berman near in this fifty year
old project it inside harbor
he's met with the
representatives of Selanne
beach and senators. And been in
contact with the army corps of
engineer trying to move forward
these projects for Sandra
punishment to help to protect
the beaches. And I'm he's also
worked with surgery dina and
all oaks down at their table.
So he is all over and I just
didn't know it is a joint
effort. And they do have a
federal current member whose
work. Hard if you seeking
monies allusions and if you
have any questions you have any
suggestions as they said all
right now is the time to bring
them forward when you bring
them to us we make sure they
get straight to DC to our
policy people and we're taking
action on them so I'm here if
anybody. Has any suggestions or
wants to make contact. Thank
you and thank you for doing
this. Thank you Francine. It's
wonderful to know that we have
a congressman who. Is working
so closely with us I know we
have a meeting coming up am-
and- play on- and replenishment
issue in some of the real order
issues that. Councilmember
hands he was talking about so.
It's great to know that we're
all working. Among all
agencies. Are really towards
the same goal so- we managed to
five minutes early which I've
never and in a meeting five
minutes early so. You know good
on you for being concise. Thank
you so much for attending I
really appreciate it. Sec
around. For a little bit to
answer any questions do we have
any comments the speakers.
Sorry any. The job so that's
good- but thank you all for
being here off the ground for a
little bit. Hi my times up to.
Thank you